Okay, good morning. So this class we are
focusing on William Shakespeare. But
before I do that, I want to give you an
overview of how we will end the course.
To end the course we will we will focus
on the four great modern civilizations
that have fought for global dominance
these past 20 years. These four great
civilizations are the Russians, the
Germans, the British and the Americans.
Now what's interesting about all four
civilizations is that they all claim to
be the the
ultimate Christian civilizations that
are here to roam.
But because of the differences in their
geography
and their culture, they have different
interpretations of Christianity and
Roman-ness. Okay, so let's compare and
contrast these four great civilizations.
The Russians as you know Russia is the
largest land mass in the world. It is
huge.
It is also really cold and dark. Okay,
so the geography
um transformed the Russian character.
Okay,
um Germany in contrast it is within
Europe and it does not have natural
boundaries that the other nations have.
It has always been attacked and
threatened by adversaries.
Okay. Um the British it's an island
fortress.
The Americans
are the most interesting because it is a
continental fortress. It is not only
invincible, it cannot be invaded, but
also has all the resources it needs in
order to have a thriving modern economy.
Therefore, America can choose to isolate
itself from the rest of the world.
Okay. Now because of the differences in
geography, you have differences in
Christianity and in its Roman-ness. So
the Russians believe that they are here
to the Byzantine Empire. And as such
they are the protectors of something
called Eastern Orthodoxy. Okay, so to
understand what Eastern Orthodoxy is,
think of Augustine. Okay, we read
Augustine, City of God. So it is a very
mystical, metaphorical
um collectivist
attitude towards religion.
In contrast, the Germans believe that
they are here to the Holy Roman Empire
first initiated by Charlemagne. And as
such they are more Catholic than the
Russians, okay. Then you have the
British who believe they are here to the
real Roman Empire um and their religion
is
Anglicanism. Okay, remember Anglicanism
there's really really little difference
between Catholicism and Anglicanism, and
Anglicanism when you Anglicanism you
swear allegiance to the King of England,
and Catholicism you swear allegiance to
the Pope of the Vatican. Um
and then you have the Americans who have
a who believe that they are the heirs to
the Roman Republic, okay, not the
Empire, the Republic before the time of
Julius Caesar, the best form of
government in the world. Um their
religion so the elite is something we
call
deist, okay. So they believe in God, but
God as someone who is removed from the
world. You also have many different
sects of Protestantism, okay. So the
religion in America it is very diffuse,
very diverse.
Okay, so um
different cultural cultural all the
different cultural outlooks will also
determine their cultural identities. So
for example, the Russians
they have the thing that differentiates
the Russians is they have a very dark
imagination. So some of the greatest
literature, some of the greatest music,
philosophy actually comes from Russia.
So think of Tolstoy. Dostoyevsky. In
terms of music you have Tchaikovsky and
Stravinsky.
Okay, I will also show you
that
the Russians produce the greatest
geopolitical leaders in history. So in
the 20th century the greatest
geopolitical leader was actually Joseph
Stalin and I will show you I'll show you
this is the case when we move to the
20th century.
Today the greatest geopolitical leader
in the world is Vladimir Putin. So
there's something about the Russian dark
imagination that produces men of genius
to lead their countries.
Um the Russian cultural identity is the
idea of Mother Russia, the land itself,
the nation, the people. It is divine.
All right, and so the main objective of
all Russian geopolitical leaders is to
protect its borders from enemies.
Because because Russia is so huge, it
encompasses two continents,
it has a lot of geopolitical enemies,
okay. So that's the Russian
civilization. We we move to the Germans.
The Germans are really interesting
because the Germans have also one of the
great human civilizations in history.
Okay, so rather than a dark imagination,
the Germans believe in the idea of will
to power. We will discuss this when we
discuss German philosophy, especially
Nietzsche. Okay, but the idea is this
that we have the capacity to impose our
will on reality. That's the idea of will
to power. We don't we are not subject to
culture, we're not subject to reality.
There are great men among us who can
impose their will on all of us. Okay,
and that's why you have Hitler and the
Nazis, okay.
The
what the Germans believe in is the idea
of Lebensraum, okay. Lebensraum. I know
this is a hard word, it's a German word,
but it's actually a pretty easy concept.
The concept is called living space. So
throughout its history German the German
people have always been invaded,
attacked by its adversaries. So to
protect itself it needs living space. It
needs to move out and colonize its
surrounding territories, Poland,
Russia, Austria, and make it more German
so that the German nation can thrive.
Okay, very simple concept, okay. But
this is the concept that drives the
German
military strategy in World War I and
World War II.
Okay, Lebensraum.
You have the British and the British as
we discussed last class, they are a very
practical people. Their philosophy is
imperialism and utilitarianism, okay.
It's not a question of what is right or
what is ideal, it's a question of what
works now. Okay, the British are
extremely practical.
The British Empire is based on the
concept of white man's burden. Meaning
that the British culture is inherently
superior
to all other cultures. And as such the
British have a responsibility to go out
and civilize and educate and enlighten
all others, okay. So this is the
philosophy that drives the British
Empire.
The Americans are interesting because
they are a new civilization and they try
to base their culture on the ideas of
the Enlightenment, okay. So we're
so-called
especially John Locke. Um
their driving ideology is the idea of
manifest destiny.
So the idea of manifest destiny is that
it is the obvious will of God for
America to control the entire Western
Hemisphere.
That's why Trump today is saying we
should take over Canada, we should take
over Greenland because that's always
been part
of the American understanding of the
world. It is God's will that America
will eventually control all the entire
Western Hemisphere. And Canada will
eventually come into America as well and
eventually America will drive out all
European powers including Denmark and
Britain from the Western Hemisphere.
Okay, so next class we will discuss
America in greater detail.
Today we will focus on the British
Empire which is founded by William
Shakespeare, okay. So we will discuss
William Shakespeare today.
Next week we'll start to focus on the
Russians and the Germans, okay. But
these are the four great civilizations
that will drive history from from the
19th century up to today.
Okay, and I will also show you later on
that
it is actually the conflict
between these four great civilizations
that will drive human creativity,
science, technology
um philosophy, okay. And that's why from
about 1800 up until um 2000 you had a
tremendous
flowering of ideas and culture.
Okay.
All right. So that's the game plan for
the rest of semester. Any questions
about this
framework?
Again, you don't have to know these
ideas right away. I will explain them in
detail to you as we move forward, okay.
But understand the overall framework is
there are four different civilizations
that will drive human um modernity and
they are in conflict with with each
other. And it's because of this conflict
that drives human innovation.
All right.
Okay, let's move on.
So the Shakes- the question we're
looking at today is
how did Shakespeare transform English
into the language of empire? So for the
longest time English is what they what
they spoke on the British Isles, okay. I
mean the British Isles primarily in
England.
So how did Shakespeare transform that
into the language that everyone speaks
today, okay. English really is the
language of empire. You think when you
learn English you're not just learning
grammar and vocabulary, you are really
learning a culture, a philosophy, and
identity.
All right. And what's amazing about
English is that it has really created
um it's really through soft power
convince everyone to believe that
Anglo-American culture is really the
best in the world when objectively
speaking it is not. You can make the
argument that Russian and German culture
is far superior to Anglo-American
culture, but everyone, especially young
people in the world today, believes that
Anglo-American culture is just vastly
superior. And the reason why is because
most people speak English, and we absorb
um
um our understanding of the world
through language, okay? All right. So,
that's the question we're looking at
today.
All right.
So, before we talk about Shakespeare, I
want you to understand some basic
principles about language, art, culture,
and civilization, okay? The first major
principle is great art, okay? Dante,
Homer,
uh Vermeer, Shakespeare. It lifts the
soul of civilization and changes the
neurological neurological structure of
societies, creating a new way of being
and seeing, okay?
So, this is a really important idea
where you have to understand that
civilization has a collective
consciousness. And what great art does
is it seeps into this collective
consciousness and rewires the brain to
make the civilization see the world in a
new way,
which causes people to behave
differently, okay? So, we discussed this
about Homer and Dante, right? Especially
Homer and Dante. Today, I'll show you
how Shakespeare radically transformed
the English imagination.
All right. Another idea I need I need
you I need you to understand is
how poets transform civilization is they
innovate in imagery,
grammar, and vocabulary, okay? And when
they do that, poets expand a
civilization's capacity to imagine,
feel, and think.
Okay?
So, um
we will discuss William Shakespeare.
William Shakespeare did not live very
long. He died at 52, okay? So, he was
not alive for a very long time, but his
accomplishments are amazing.
In his brief life, he wrote anywhere
between 38 to 41 plays, and he
established the English cultural
identity, okay? Shakespeare is really
the founder of English culture,
and he established the his English
historical memory, okay? And he did this
by writing a lot of plays, right? So,
tragedies, histories, comedies. You've
read some of them in in in um in in
school,
right? So, his accomplishments are
tremendous. The reason why we don't know
how many plays he actually wrote, okay,
is he never published in his lifetime.
All his plays were published after his
death by his friends who are working
with his notes as well as as um
recollections from actors who
participated in Shakespeare's plays.
That's why So, we don't have actually
anything written specifically by
Shakespeare, okay?
So, keep that in mind.
Um in his plays, he used anywhere
between 20,000 to 30,000 different
words. So, his range of vocabulary was
just vast.
What's really unique about Shakespeare
is he introduced anywhere between 1,700
to 3,500 new uses of words, what we call
a diction, okay?
I I'll show you what diction is later
on.
To put this in context, between the
years 1500 and 1650, around 10,000 new
words are being introduced into into
England because of
revolutions in agriculture, in trade, um
in communication, in technology, okay?
So, at this point in history, England is
um going out into the world, and it's
transforming its society, and therefore
it needs to bring in new words.
What Shakespeare does that's really
important is he transforms
the British imagination
in order to better um
absorb these new ideas. And he does so
through
new new uses of words, what we call a
diction, okay?
So, this makes sense, guys, okay? So,
let's let's examine how he does this.
Let's Let me give you an example. Let's
look at the word dagger, okay? Dagger
means just a short sword, okay? And it's
a very common English word.
But what Shakespeare does is he uses it
in a really imaginative metaphorical way
that forces you to reimagine the world
around you, okay? So, let's look at some
examples. And these are my examples, by
by the way. They're not Shakespeare's
examples, all right? We will look at
Shakespeare's examples later on. All
right. So, the first example is here's a
dagger, fat and short. Okay, this is
interesting because we see a dagger, we
think of something that is
um thin, right? And this is saying this
is fat.
All right. So, this forces you to to
think about what dagger is as a
metaphor.
And this makes your mind think, "Oh,
here's a dagger, fat and short." So, is
it possible that on the surface he looks
fat and short, but actually, as a
person, he is lean and mean. He's very
very clever. He pretends he's stupid,
but he has he has very precise
um cleverness, okay?
All right. So, that's what Shakespeare
does. He takes a traditional metaphor
and he radically reverses or inverts it
to force you to reimagine things in a
new way.
All right. That's the first example.
Second example is
I daggered him with questions. Now, the
word dagger actually exists in English
language, but it means you carry dagger
with you, okay? So, if I say, "I am
daggered," it means my there's a dagger
in my pocket. And that's the traditional
use of dagger. But there's no reason why
you can't do what Shakespeare does and
says, "I daggered him with questions,"
which means like I stab him with
questions, all right? I'm stabbing him
with questions. I ask a lot of
questions.
And this is very visual, it's very
imaginative, okay? Now, the third
example is
his voice is daggerly. Daggerly as a
word does not exist, but because you
know what the word dagger means, you can
imagine what daggerly could mean, right?
A voice that is like mine, very high,
high, high,
okay? And which
you feel
um is stabbing at you,
all right? So, that's the
genius of Shakespeare. He takes
words that we use every day, and he
finds new ways of using it in his plays
that forces us to reimagine the world in
a different way.
All right. That's the power of
Shakespeare.
Now,
um what this is saying is this. What
Shakespeare understands is that
language can be a portal into the
neurological framework of our minds,
right? So, you might have some studied
some neuroscience or psychology, you
know like our brain is structured by
these things called synapses, okay?
These pathways in our brain.
And what Shakespeare understands is that
by
by manipulating language in a new way,
you can also perform a sort of surgery
on the synapses,
all right?
All right.
So,
Shakespeare as music. The thing you you
remember about about Shakespeare is his
plays were meant to be performed as
musicals, okay?
Um today in school, we have you read
Shakespeare, but remember, during the
time of Shakespeare, no one read him.
You experience Shakespeare by going to
his plays, and his plays were musicals.
Uh when people spoke Shakespeare, it was
as though they were singing.
And also, there were lots of like dance
routines within the plays as well.
Remember, these are people who are
extremely ordinary, okay? Who are going
to Shakespeare as a form of mass
entertainment. It's almost like the
equivalent of like going to movies
today.
And the way that Shakespeare creates
music in his plays is through a device
called iambic pentameter.
Okay? Iambic pentameter
um you know, right? It's um iambus is
just uh the arrangement of syllables
where you have one one that is deep and
then another that's high.
So, deep, high, deep, high, deep, high,
deep, high, deep, high. When you have 10
syllables, it's called pentameter, okay?
So, an example, of course, is to be or
not to be. That is the question.
So, So, you you you understand how this
works, right? Low, high, low, high, low,
high. And Shakespeare does that
throughout his plays. That's why it
comes across as musical. But if it's
musical, then then it's easy to remember
because it becomes like a song, right?
It's really easy for us to remember
songs.
So,
through iambic pentameter, Shakespeare's
plays are memorable, beautiful, and
resonant, meaning they touch our souls.
And again, these are ordinary people.
So, through iambic pentameter,
Shakespeare's performing a surgery on
the imagination of civilization, all
right?
All right.
So, having said that,
let's go into some brief history about
Shakespeare.
Um
during the time of Shakespeare,
theater is extremely popular around the
country,
and theater is primarily the means of
mass entertainment, but it's also the
means of mass education. If you want to
know about history, if you want to know
about culture,
you go to the theater. The problem with
this is that during the time of
Shakespeare, around the 16th century, as
we discussed last class, there's a major
conflict going on between the Protestant
religion and the Catholic religion.
And so the the queen, Queen Elizabeth,
is concerned about theater as a means of
creating dissent in society. So what
they do is they force all the theater
productions to be placed in a suburb of
London. Okay, and that's where
Shakespeare is going to work. By doing
that, Shakespeare is being introduced to
all the major theater of that time.
Okay? So Shakespeare never actually
wrote anything that is unique. Okay? So
Hamlet, Julius Caesar, Othello, King
Lear, these are all plays that are
part of the British theatrical
imagination. But what he does that's
different is he reimagines the
characters and introduces new diction
into the plays to make it beautiful. All
right? So this is the Globe, which is
where Shakespeare performed much of his
productions. All right? The Globe
Theater.
The thing also to remember about this
time is theater is low class.
All right? So in this district, the
fifth the fifth district, there are lots
of brothels.
People go to theater and they get drunk,
okay? They're drinking, they're
spitting, they're eating stuff. They're
also partici- participate in something
called an illegal activity called bear
baiting, okay? Bear baiting is really
strange, but the idea is you take a
bear, you chain him up,
you blind him, okay? And then you have
dogs attack him. And then you bet who
wins, the bear or the dogs. And this is
a really popular thing to do at this
time. All right? So it just shows you
that we think of Shakespeare as very
high class, and we teach Shakespeare as
high class, but at this time Shakespeare
is very very low class. And
Shakespeare's plays are performed
right beside bear baiting
venues as well as brothels. All right?
But this is important because
because if Shakespeare is reaching to
the masses,
right? He's educating the masses into a
global imagination.
All right. Shakespeare
and theater is so detested by the upper
class that from 1642 to 1660, the
Puritans banned it from England. Okay,
remember we discussed the Puritans and
how they're obsessed with
control. They hate alcohol, they hate
fun, they hate theater, especially
theater. They hate Shakespeare, okay? So
they banned it. So during this time,
Shakespeare is extremely controversial.
So
having gone into the history, let's
discuss the genius of Shakespeare, okay?
You you do Shakespeare in school, you've
read quite a few of his plays, so I'm
not going to go too deeply, but I'm
going to focus on one example that
distinguishes
Shakespeare from all other playwrights,
okay? So the example I want to use is
Hamlet. Okay, Hamlet, the story you
know, it's a very simple story. It's
about this prince of Denmark called
Hamlet. He's going to university
in
um
Germany,
I believe Wittenberg, which is where
Martin Luther went. He comes home, and
he's visited by the ghost of his dead
father. And the ghost of his dead father
tells Hamlet,
"I was killed by your uncle Claudius,
who now has stolen the throne from me,
as well as married my wife Gertrude,
your mother. It is your responsibility
as my son to seek vengeance against
Claudius." Okay? So that's the mission
of Hamlet. The problem is that Hamlet,
he is a very
analytical person. He thinks too much.
Paralysis is analysis, okay? So he
spends the whole play thinking about how
to kill him, kill Claudius, but also
whether or not to kill Claudius. And
this is why we believe that Hamlet is
Shakespeare's best play because it is a
very deep philosophical work. And in
many ways, Hamlet is really the
expression of Shakespeare.
You may not know this, but Shakespeare
had a son called Hamnet, and Hamnet
actually died when he was young. So a
lot of scholars of Shakespeare, and
there are like thousands of scholars on
Shakespeare, believe Hamlet is
Shakespeare's most personal play.
All right. So we're going to go into a
bit of Shakespeare and look at the most
famous soliloquy in Shakespeare to
understand how he thinks, how he writes.
All right? So
This again, this is iambic pentameter.
To be or not to be, that is the
question. Whether 'tis nobler in the
mind to suffer the slings and arrows of
outrageous fortune, or to take arms
against a sea of troubles, and by
opposing end them. To die, to sleep, no
more. And by a sleep to say we end the
heartache and the thousand natural
shocks
that flesh is heir to. 'Tis a
consummation devoutly to be wished. To
die, to sleep. To sleep, perchance to
dream. Ay, there's the rub. For in that
sleep of death what dreams may come when
we have shuffled off this mortal coil
must give us pause. There's the respect
that makes calamity of so long life.
Does conscience doth make cowards of us
all, and thus the native hue of
resolution is sicklied o'er with the
pale cast of thought, and enterprises of
great pith and moment with this regard
their currents turn awry and lose the
name of action. Okay.
So some brief comments about the
soliloquy. First of all, as you can
understand, it's beautiful. Right? It's
also, if you think about it, pretty easy
to read. There are lots of really
complicated words in the speech, but
it's really smooth, right? If you read
it for yourself, it's really smooth. And
that's the power of iambic pentameter.
If you really want to be fluent in
English,
just read Shakespeare aloud for a few
months, and your English will be
perfect, okay? The British really are
the best practitioners of English. If
you read magazines like The Economist,
it's really the
best written magazine in the world. And
you think to yourself, "Well, duh, the
British invented English." Right?
No, okay? Just because you invent
something doesn't mean you're good at
it. So the Chinese invented gunpowder,
compass, printing, paper, didn't really
get us anywhere, okay? The fact of the
matter is that in England, you're
expected to read and know Shakespeare.
All right? So it's Shakespeare that
allows the British to have amazing
English. All right. So this is very
complicated, but it's actually not that
deep, okay? It's not like Dante. Dante
is very very deep, but Shakespeare is
actually not that deep. All right? So
let's look at what actually means with
these words. Okay? To be or not to be,
that is the question. Against the
misfortune in our lives, is it more
brave and good to bear it or to stand
against it? I no longer want to bear
this pain. Let me sleep. I no longer
want to feel my heartache and my body
become weak and injured. That is my
wish. I want to sleep and to dream, but
that is a danger, isn't it? When we are
dead, we cannot control what we dream,
and that is what frightens me. That's
why I continue to bear the more
misfortunes around me. It is my own mind
that has made me a coward, and why each
time when I become determined, my
resolve breaks apart and I cannot act.
Okay? That's what he's saying. That's
like literally what he's saying. No
difference.
But of course, when you do this, when
you simplify Shakespeare, you lose the
beauty and richness of Shakespeare. All
right? So now the question then is,
why is Shakespeare so complicated?
What's he trying to do with his
language? Okay? So the first thing that
he's trying to do is he's trying to use
language as a mechanism to convey
different realities, different meanings.
Okay? So with each Shakespeare, with
each with each of his plays, there are
many different layers of meaning that
can be true at the same time. All right?
So let me show you an example of this.
Let's look at the first possible
interpretation of to be or not to be,
okay? You can say it means to die or to
live. I cannot decide. I do not know if
it's more brave to live a painful life
or to run away from it and escape into
death. So this is saying that Hamlet is
overwhelmed by the moral dilemma he's
put in, okay? He cannot
escape. He has to avenge his father,
right? Or he cannot sleep, but avenging
his father means killing his uncle, who
his mother loves, okay? It's an
impossible moral dilemma, and he doesn't
he doesn't want to deal with it. So he
wants to kill himself, okay? That's one
possible interpretation.
Another possible interpretation is to
kill or not to kill, I do not know. Is
it more good to let those who do evil
suffer their own fate, or should I stop
their evil and end their lives, okay? So
you can interpret this as saying he's
asking himself, "How should he kill
Claudius? Should he kill Claudius?"
Okay? That's a different interpretation.
Yet another interpretation is
should I follow my fate or should I defy
it? Is it more brave and good to do as I
am told or to fight against my fate and
in so doing perhaps die, okay? So this
is like more deeper and richer meaning
where he's talking about fate and life
in general. He's making the argument
that we are we have no free free will.
We are forced into a situation where we
must do what fate tells us. And in this
situation, what does it mean to be
human? What does it mean to have free
will where you're controlled by the
forces of faith around you?
Okay? So, that's a much deeper meaning.
And then the last deep meaning is
what is the point of existence? I do not
know. When we exist, we must face
pointless questions in our lives. Should
we suffer or should we fight? Okay? So,
this is the deepest meaning which ask
he's he's actually asking
what does what is existence?
What is the point of all this? How do we
get here?
What is the purpose of existence? Okay?
So, there are four possible
interpretations of the speech and
they're all
correct. You can interpret them any way
they want. Okay? So, that's the first
power of Shakespeare where he's forcing
you to interpret his speech in different
ways. Okay? The second power of
Shakespeare is
it's visual. Okay? In this tradition in
this oral culture where no one reads and
writes, well, most people don't read and
write. Uh most people are accessing the
information through
words, right? And in this tradition,
words are images. All right? So, let's
go over
the soliloquy and see how they use your
images. Okay? So, when Hamlet says
suffer the slings and arrows of
outrageous fortune or take arms against
a sea of troubles and by posing end
them, the audience is seeing these
pictures. They're seeing a movie in
their heads.
Okay? That's the attraction of
Shakespeare.
Okay, do you guys see this?
Is it clear to you guys?
All right? And because you're seeing
pictures, they remember all this. Okay?
If you when you talk to an English
person, it's amazing how much
Shakespeare that person knows
subconsciously.
Another image. Okay?
In that sleep of death, what dreams may
come when we have shuffled off this
mortal coil must give us pause.
All right? So, this is an image of a
person who's dead. So, his soul goes up
to heaven. But what's in heaven? What's
in that sleep of death? No one knows.
Okay?
Another image.
The native hue of resolution is sicklied
over with a pale cast of thought.
Okay? So, this is a complicated
sentence, but it's really about how
something that is clear to us once we
think about it becomes very dark and
unclear.
All right? So, that's the power of
Shakespeare. It's a visual language.
All right. Another example.
And enterprises of great pith and moment
their currents turn awry and lose the
name of action. All right? So, imagine a
ship. It's going very it's going in the
direction you're set on that path,
but the moment you think about it the
thing the moment you think deeply about
what you're doing,
uh the ship collapses.
You don't know where you're going
anymore.
All right? So, it is that clear to you
guys?
All right.
So, another example of the power of
Shakespeare is
uh Julius Caesar. I'm not sure if you
read Julius Caesar in
uh
school, but Julius Caesar it's a very I
mean the plot is very simple.
Um Julius Caesar
he has defeated all his enemies in the
Roman Civil War and his friends Brutus,
Cassius
um they're worried that he'll become a
dictator. They're they're worried that
he'll be he'll become king. So, they
plot to kill him.
And Brutus and Cassius and all the
conspirators kill
um Julius Caesar and then
Brutus and Cassius think this is over.
Okay? But Mark Antony who is Caesar's
lieutenant, he swears vengeance.
And Mark Antony and Octavian will
combine forces to destroy and kill
Brutus and Cassius. And that's the plot
of Julius Caesar. Not very complicated.
Okay? But
in Julius Caesar, you will find some of
the greatest speeches
in the English language.
It's stunning speeches.
Okay? And in the speeches, you will find
example of how
Shakespeare understands language as a
surgery on the brain. How through speech
making, how through language, you can
actually transform the neuro
neurological structure of the human
brain. Okay? So, let's look at example
of this.
Mark Antony and Brutus are going to
engage in a speech competition. They're
going to debate each other. Okay? Brutus
will be the first to give a speech and
then he'll be followed by Mark Antony.
So, the strategy of Brutus is is to use
a rhetorical strategy called the
antithesis. Okay? The antithesis is
basically very simple. You have two
opposing ideas, okay?
And they are opposed to each other.
So, the idea is I am Brutus. I am
honorable. You know me as honorable
because my name is Brutus which is also
name of Lucius Brutus who founded the
Roman Republic.
You know me as honorable person. Now,
who is Caesar? Caesar is ambitious.
Okay? Honor and ambition cannot go
together.
So, I love Caesar, but because he was
ambitious, he wanted to enslave us. I
want to free us.
Therefore, I had to kill him.
All right? So, that's the idea of
Brutus. He's trying to create a
dichotomy between Caesar and himself. If
you know me Brutus as honorable, then
you must believe that Caesar is
ambitious. This rhetorical strategy is
what called antithesis. Okay?
In the human mind, you just see these
two things as separate from each other.
Mark Antony then responds to Brutus
using something called the chiasmus.
Okay? The chiasmus is really
interesting. The chiasmus take tries to
take these two opposing principles and
combine them together.
All right? So, what Mark Antony will say
is that Caesar was ambitious and
honorable as honorable and ambitious as
Brutus. This is called what we call
chiasmus. It's called it's an A
B B A structure.
When you do that,
when you have a chiasmus, you collapse
the antithesis.
Remember the antithesis are two separate
ideas that cannot meet together.
Exclusionary. The chiasmus shows you
like these are mirrors of each other.
Okay?
When you do that, in the in the Roman
imagination human Roman mind, you then
collapse the economy between Brutus and
Caesar and you see them as
one in the same. But
if it was Brutus that killed Caesar,
then Brutus must be the less honorable
and ambish and more ambitious one. Okay?
Does that make sense, guys?
Julius Caesar.
All right. So, let's see an example of
this.
All right. This is Brutus
sit talking to the Roman crowd after the
death of Julius Caesar. Okay? He's
trying to explain his actions before the
Roman crowd. He says,
"If then that friend demand why Brutus
rose against Caesar, this is my answer."
Okay? You want to know why I killed
Caesar? I'm going to tell you why I
killed Caesar.
"Not that I loved Caesar less, but I
loved Rome more. Had you rather Caesar
were living and die as all slaves than
that Caesar were dead to live all free
men?"
This is an antithesis, right?
I loved Caesar,
but I loved Rome more.
Okay? This is an antithesis. This is
also antithesis.
Caesar, if you were living, he we he
would make us into slaves. If Caesar is
dead, we will continue to live as free
men. Okay? Two exclusionary ideas
developed by Brutus.
Now, what Mark Antony's going to do is
he's going to collapse this.
Okay? He's going to change your
neurological structure. He's going to
change your synapses within you through
his speech making. Let's look at Mark
Antony.
"Yet Brutus says he was ambitious and
sure he's an honorable man." Okay? So,
he's summarizing uh the argument made by
Brutus.
"I speak not to disprove what Brutus
Brutus spoke, but here I am to speak
what I do know.
You all did love him once, not without
cause. What cause withholds you then to
mourn for him?" Okay? This is a
chiasmus. Cause cause
love mourn. Okay? You guys see that?
He continues with the chiasmus.
"But yesterday, the word of Caesar might
have stood against the world. Now lies
he there and none so poor to do him
reverence.
O masters, if I were disposed to stir
your hearts and minds to mutiny and
rage, I should do Brutus wrong and
Cassius wrong who you all know are
honorable men. I will not do them wrong.
I rather choose to wrong the dead, to
wrong myself and you than I will wrong
such honorable men." Okay? This is two
examples of chiasmus where word of
Caesar and reverence match. Stood and
lies match. Okay?
Through the chiasmus, he's collapsing
this dichotomy. Another example is here.
Okay? The red match the green match.
This this is what we call chiasmus.
Does that make sense, guys?
Okay? Have you guys learned this before?
Okay? It's really important you know you
know these ideas. All right.
So, that's the power of Shakespeare.
Through his language,
through his rhetoric, he's transforming
the British imagination so that they are
more open, more fluid. They can absorb
new ideas and they can be more
innovative.
Okay?
Now, we we as we discussed way back
at the beginning of this course, Homer
did the same thing. So, let's compare
and contrast Homer and Shakespeare. How
was it able that they were both able to
be founders of great civilizations?
All right.
First of all,
they came at a time
when there's a cultural tabula rasa.
Okay?
Tabula rasa just means blank slate. So,
Homer came at a time after the Bronze
Age collapse of Greece. The Mycenaean
civilization collapsed and now you have
this the polis system. Okay? So, it's a
tabula rasa.
Same thing with Shakespeare where
Britain at this time it is not an
advanced culture as much as the French
and
the Spanish.
Second is rapid cultural change where
Britain is undergoing all these
revolutions. When you when it's
undergoing all these revolutions people
are anxious and they're looking for new
ideas.
Oral culture, okay? We we talked about
this where if you live in an oral
culture people have a stronger memory
and have a greater imagination. That's
why they're able to sit through three
hours of Shakespeare at one go at at one
one go and visualize his language. And
this is like the most common person in
Britain, okay? These are not the elite.
These are just commoners.
And so
with an oral culture have a stronger
memory, imagery, vibrancy, and
flexibility. They they
look guys I I hate to say this but back
then they were smarter than we are
today.
We have you know Google and ChatGPT, but
if you think about it all these things
are just making us stupid, okay?
Um open corporate competition just means
that in their times Homer was just one
of thousands of bards that are traveling
around
Greece and singing legends of the Trojan
War and the Golden Fleece.
Okay? So what they were doing was they
were stealing from each other. All
right? Shakespeare was stealing from
everyone else.
And that allows for rapid innovation.
When when when you have an open
corporate competition.
Democratic sensibilities. This is really
important. Okay? Homer was talking to
ordinary people. Shakespeare was talking
to ordinary people. The problem with
today's culture is
there's a lot of market differentiation
where if you feel that you are high
class, you're a university professor,
you don't want to talk to common people,
you want to talk to other university
professors. That leads to stagnation and
segmentation, okay? Free market. Really
important idea where
how do you know if you're good or not,
okay? Well, in a university you know if
you're good or not if your professor
tells you you're good or not. But how do
you know the professor knows what he's
talking about? The free market provides
an objective feedback loop which forces
you to constantly innovate and improve,
right?
How do you know you're good because
people come and listen to you. They pay
attention to your plays. They want to
pay for your plays.
All right? And it turned out that
because of the free market
corporate competition Shakespeare proved
to be the best. Okay?
And the last idea is poet as prophet,
okay? This is really important idea
where
okay, yes, Shakespeare became very
wealthy because
of the plays he was producing. He was he
came from a very common background. He
was not very wealthy. He didn't even go
to university.
That's why that's why today there are
scholars who believe Shakespeare did not
write Shakespeare because he didn't go
to Oxford or Cambridge. Christopher
Marlowe wrote went to Oxford or
Cambridge but not Shakespeare. Okay? So
you have a lot of scholars who actually
believe because he was he was not well
educated he
could not have written the plays he
wrote.
But what drove Shakespeare and what
drove Homer is the idea that you have a
divine mission to spread the truth.
Okay? So Shakespeare and Homer they were
rich, they were popular, they were
famous, but they were not driven by
money. They were driven by a divine
Messianic mission to transform the
world.
Okay?
Does that make sense, guys? This is
really important to understand.
Great artists are driven by
a Messianic mission to change the world
for the better. They're not driven by
money
or power or fame. All right.
So having done that, let's recap and
summarize the three great poets that
have impacted Western civilization,
okay? And compare and contrast the
three. All right, you have Homer who
founded the Greek civilization. You have
Dante who we discussed in great detail
this semester. He's the founder of
modernity. And you have Shakespeare who
is the founder of the British Empire.
All right? So
um again, Homer, Dante, and Shakespeare
were all democrats in their heart. Homer
was a roaming bard who went around the
different polices to
sing and entertain the masses. Dante was
revolutionary because he wrote the
Divine Comedy not in Latin which was the
language of the educated elite but in
the vernacular in Tuscan so that
ordinary people could access it. And by
doing so he transformed Tuscan into the
official Italian language that is spoken
today.
Who
Shakespeare again was a playwright. He
wrote and entertained the masses. That's
why in Shakespeare you have such I mean
it's it's it's very
offensive some of his language, okay?
All right.
Um they have different conceptions of
language though.
All right? And this is very key for us
to remember. For Homer language is a
window into the human soul. So like go
back to the Iliad and the Odyssey. It
was really about what drove us humans.
Achilles was driven by the thirst for
fame.
Odysseus was driven by his love of
Penelope and his son Telemachus, okay?
So both the Iliad and the Odyssey were
tremendous
psychological studies of what it means
to be human. Then you have Dante, all
right? Dante uses language as a portal
into the mind of God. What is the
universe? How did God create the
universe? What does God want from us?
Okay, that's the Divine Comedy.
Shakespeare is very different, okay?
Shakespeare creates a new idea of
language as a reality onto itself.
All right? A reality onto itself. So
what I mean by that is with Shakespeare
it's not really a deep meaning. It's
very hard to find deep truths in
Shakespeare. But the language is
beautiful. And this is the culture we
live in today where you know what?
People write novels, they use beautiful
language, beautiful description, great
imagery, but there's really not great
truths, deep truths, grand truths in the
novels that are written and produced
today, okay? So let me give you an
example of what it means to have
language as reality onto itself.
All right? So let
let me show you show you show you what
this means. And to do so I'm going to
I'm going to use a different
poet. His name is John Keats.
Okay, John Keats.
And this is from his most famous poem to
autumn which is considered the greatest
English poem of all time, all right? So
let's read it together and then I'll
show you how this is a reality onto
itself.
Where are the songs of spring? I where
are they? Think not of them. Thou hast
thy music too. While barred clouds bloom
the soft dying day and touch the stubble
plains with rosy hue. Then in a wailful
choir the small gnats mourn among the
river shallows born aloft or sinking as
the wind lives or dies. And full-grown
lambs loud bleat from hilly bourn.
Hedge-crickets sing and now with treble
soft the redbreast whistles from my
garden-croft and gathering swallows
twitter in the skies. Okay. So it's
beautiful. What does it mean?
All right.
I'm going to show you what it means,
okay?
This is this is language as a reality
onto itself. It is language visualizing
a new world, all right? So you see how
the words match, right? While barred
clouds bloom the soft dying day and
touch the stubble plains with rosy hue.
It's a painting, guys.
All right?
This one sentence it's a painting
of a new world that you can see in your
heart.
Also
then in a wailful choir the small gnats
mourn among the river shallows born
aloft or sinking as
as the light wind lives or dies.
Okay? You can see the music within this
picture.
All right?
This is a not just a picture but it's a
world that you can access because it's
moving. It's alive. It's the power of
language.
Next sentence.
And full-grown lambs loud bleat from
hilly bourn.
Hedge-crickets sing and now with treble
soft the redbreast whistles from my
garden-croft. Okay? So you see what's
happening where this poetry it is
entering your soul. It is it is
activating all your emotions, all your
senses. There's the visual. Okay?
There's a sound.
There's the smell. There's the touch.
And gathering swallows twitter in the
skies.
Okay?
That's what poetry is. Poetry is the
expression of a new world that you can
access.
All right? And when you access it when
you enter it it transforms your soul
and your imagination, your capacity to
think, feel, and imagine.
Okay? Does that make sense to you guys?
All right.
So let's summarize what we learned,
okay? Shakespeare turns English into the
world's linguistic internet.
A platform in which all cultures, ideas,
and worldviews can meet and crossbreed.
Okay? So Shakespeare is transforming
English into this extremely flexible,
beautiful,
memorable language which allows everyone
to learn English well. You want to learn
English well, just read Shakespeare.
Okay? That's all you have to do. And
then you can master English.
So, it's a linguistic internet.
For the first time, all cultures are
able to meet together
in within the English language and
communicate with each other.
Okay? There's a problem with this.
There's a problem with this. The problem
is this.
But this exchange is mediated through
Anglo-American civilization which is at
its heart utilitarian, skeptical, and
empirical.
All right? So, when you embrace English,
when you experience English, you're also
experiencing
British culture, history, and
philosophy. Okay? And as we discussed,
the three main philosophies of British
culture are utilitarian, skeptical, and
empirical. Utilitarian we discussed last
class. It just means that
um
we should do things that works as
opposed to what is right.
Skeptical is
to be skeptical of our capacity
to reason and to think. If you think you
know something, you probably don't know
it.
Okay?
And then empirical just means the only
thing you can know is things you
experience.
All right?
So, in other words, Anglo-American
culture, even though it dominates the
world, it's
it's pretty lacklustre. It's very
narrow-minded. It's very practical. It's
pretty mediocre.
Okay? And if you want to
know what I mean by that, think about
think think to yourself.
What What was the What was the last
great American novel you read?
I mean, there are lots of great Russian,
German novels, right? So, Russian
Russians you have Anna Karenina, War and
Peace,
Crime and Punishment. The Germans have
great philosophy, Kant, Nietzsche,
Hegel. We'll We'll We'll go into that uh
later on, okay? But I I struggle to
think about what great art
the Americans produce have produced,
even though they are the most wealthy,
most powerful country that has ever
existed in human history.
Okay?
And I mean, Shakespeare's great. I mean,
like like like I love Shakespeare. King
Lear is one of the greatest plays ever
written, but Shakespeare compared with
Dante, I mean, I don't know, okay? Dante
is like you are in the mind of God.
You can feel this is divine, okay? But
with Shakespeare, you're like, this is
beautiful, but
is it a pretty nothingness?
Okay?
That's the question I I have. And again,
to be fair,
it's been a long time since I actually
read read Shakespeare. I've read most of
his plays. Um but it's been a long time
since I've read Shakespeare. So, what I
want to do later on
um may may maybe a few years from now is
actually teach Shakespeare and see if
I'm wrong, okay? But
um right now I I I have to say
Shakespeare is not as impressive as
Homer and Dante.
All right? I think Homer and Dante are
the two greatest poets who ever lived.
All right.
So, let me give an example of what I
mean by
how British culture is kind of
narrow-minded. All right. So, this is
considered the greatest
epic in the English tradition called
Paradise Lost by John Milton.
And it's really about um Adam and Eve,
right? Why did Adam and Eve eat that
forbidden fruit? And why were we
banished from uh the Garden of Eden? And
look, um it's 12 books which is modeled
off
the great epics of antiquity, um
Homer and uh Virgil. And there are some
parts of
Paradise Lost which are
beautiful, okay? I mean, I love Paradise
Lost. I I've taught Paradise Lost
before. But the reality is this.
As an epic, as a grand vision of the
world, it doesn't really work.
Okay? I mean, like
um
I don't really
think the plot, the vision of Paradise
Lost is as fully formed
and as grand as Homer and as Virgil and
as Dante, okay? And so, Paradise Lost,
you you might have a chance to read it
um
in college one day, but it's a very
limited and narrow-minded
uh
epic.
All right. So,
so let's conclude.
All right? So, we we did Britain today,
okay? And I hope you understand
uh
British culture. It's an island
fortress.
It sees itself as heir to the Roman
Empire. It is an Anglican religion. It's
driven by
the empir- empiricists and utilitarian
philosophies, okay? And Shakespeare is
really the founder of this great
civilization. Next class we'll do
America.
Okay? And then after we do these two uh
cultures that now dominate the world,
we'll move on to the Germans and the
Russians.
Okay? That's the game plan. But was
today's class clear to you?
Do you understand Shakespeare now?
Does this make sense?
Okay? Any questions?
Anything you want to clear about? Any
questions?
So, so I think you mentioned that
like all of the plays
about Shakespeare stuff have been
published like after he had died. So, is
that like those plays held in theaters,
but they weren't like
the
like the textual version of it haven't
been published for years and like Okay,
yeah. So, okay. So, the question is,
what is
like
like so, Shakespeare's is played out is
is performed
all the time and you are forced to read
Shakespeare in school. So, where is
Where do we get these plays from?
Okay? So, uh let me explain to you
what's happening.
All right.
Okay. So,
Shakespeare's plays. All right. So,
when Shakespeare was alive,
um he didn't really publish
his plays.
Okay? He didn't publish his plays. And
there were many reasons why he didn't
publish his plays. Um first of all, in
this culture at this time, there's no
copyright.
So, if you publish your play and someone
steals it, too bad. So, you're not
incentivized to publish your play.
Second of all,
people don't really read it, right? So,
there's really no market for his plays.
So, even if he were to publish his
plays, he wouldn't make any money he
would he would make any money he would
not make any money off it, okay? So,
what he did was he wrote his plays down
um primarily for his actors to memorize.
But as But But the But But the benefit
of iambic pentameter is that actually
the speeches are pretty easy to
memorize.
Okay?
And um when he was alive, Shakespeare
was a national celebrity. He performed
his plays in front of the king and
queen. He was very very very well known,
um
extremely famous. Um He was looked down
upon by the nobles, but I mean, he was
very very wealthy. And he himself will
go on to purchase a noble title for
himself, okay? So, he he was extremely
successful.
Um
when he was alive,
people didn't really fully understand
his genius, okay? It's only about 100
years, 20 years afterwards
uh when people really appreciate his
genius.
And his
plays spread throughout Europe,
especially to Germany to Germany. The
Germans love Shakespeare, okay? And it
was only after his death that people
realized what a
um
unique genius Shakespeare was.
So,
um after his death,
um his friends, and I don't remember
their names, okay? But his friends want
to uh remember him. They want to
memorize him, okay? So, they start to
publish his plays. It's It's something
called the First Folio.
So, basically, what they did was, okay?
They took um the notes from Shakespeare.
So, some of surviving manuscripts, not
complete, okay? But some of his notes.
They also
got the actors to basically write down
what uh they
uh remember, okay? And they remember a
lot because these actors These actors
have extremely
um good memories, okay? So, they were
able to reme- remember exactly
uh the speeches.
Um and then they'll make they'll make
edits, okay?
And this is the First Folio. First fo-
fo- folio, okay? But as you can imagine,
over time, there'll be a lot lots of
additions and mistakes.
All right?
But um so, today
it There are thousands of Shakespeare
scholars and they argue over certain
words.
Did Shakespeare really have this word
or was it a later addition, okay? And I
mean
it's a really silly thing to do because
as I explained to you the genius of
Shakespeare was to imagine language as
this very fluid,
um, flexible,
imaginative tool for you to experience
reality onto itself, okay?
So to argue what what I mean like was
was it dagger or datter
or dasher, okay? And people argue this.
I mean like does it really matter? I
mean like a lot of Shakespeare is just
word play, right? I mean like there's
really no deep truth in Shakespeare. And
quite honestly
I mean like
these words are I'm not going to change
the deeper meaning of Shakespeare, okay?
So so it's just something that
I think
overpaid English professors do,
okay? Just because
they have nothing better to do, okay?
They argue about what was the in the
first folio, what was edited out, was
added to. They try to figure out what
was Shakespeare's original intention.
And I mean Shakespeare, think of him as
a musician, okay? He's I mean like he's
trying to,
um,
sing beauty and truth.
But a lot of it is not intentional. A
lot of it is not conscious. A lot of it
is just being driven by inspiration and
intuition and imagination, okay?
Right? So when we go back to Hamlet the
soliloquy, if we change a few words it
doesn't really change the meaning of the
soliloquy, okay?
Right?
Does it make sense, Eva? Okay, great
question though, right?
Any other questions?
Okay, okay. So it's a great question,
okay? Um,
what man's burden?
Okay, this is a concept that was
introduced during the age of
imperialism, right? At the end towards
the end of the 19th century by Robert
Kipling, okay? The white man's burden.
The responsibility as white people to go
and civilize the dark people, okay? In
Africa and in China and other places.
Um, what's the connection to
Shakespeare?
Okay, first of all
Shakespeare
was not interested in the world, okay?
He he was a very provincial. He was
interested in London and that was about
it. I'm not even sure if he traveled,
okay? Um, there's a debate whether or
not he actually speaks French and Latin.
He knows a bit of Latin but there's a
debate whether or not he speaks French,
okay? So,
um, Shakespeare was not an imperialist.
He was not a globalist. He didn't really
care about the world.
But
within Shakespeare is British culture,
okay? He wrote of histories,
tragedies,
and comedies.
There's like 38 to 41 plays
and together
they are the encapsulation of British
culture,
right? So as Britain was going out into
the world and conquering people
and colonizing nations they needed to
explain why this this was happening,
okay? Why are you going and killing
people for like no particular reason?
And this is why Shakespeare is important
because Shakespeare
allows them to say, "Well, do you have a
Shakespeare? Do you have Do you have
like 38 to 41 plays that are really
written? Well, if you don't then that
means you're not civilized,
okay? We have Shakespeare, you don't
have Shakespeare, that means we're
superior to you
and therefore we will teach you
Shakespeare. We will educate you in
Shakespeare.
We will civilize you, okay?"
So this is not just Shakespeare. There
are other,
um,
individuals as well, okay? But primarily
Shakespeare.
Shakespeare is really the,
um,
greatest cultural product of the
British,
right?
So that
Does it make sense, Echo?
Okay, so Shakespeare himself was not an
imperialist. He didn't really care about
that sort of thing, okay? But his legacy
will be co-opted by British imperialists
in order to justify and explain why
they're going out and killing so many
people around the world
and stealing the resources,
right?
Yeah, but we'll discuss this when we
enter the age of imperialism which is
towards the 19th century. And and then
this will lead us into the great wars.
World War uh, World War I and World War
II.
All right.
Any more questions?
Yeah, I I I understand the question,
okay? Great. Great. So so you're you're
doing Othello in class and you're
looking at Othello from the perspective
of race and identity and culture, right?
Um,
okay.
So
let's discuss how Shakespeare wrote his
plays,
okay? So he wrote, um,
for around 40 plays before he died at at
52, okay? Which meant that he was
basically producing
one, two, three plays a year. That's a
lot, guys.
If you read Shakespeare the themes are
extremely diverse, okay? You have
Othello who is a Moor
who kills his wife Desdemona,
okay?
But you also have
Merchant of Venice,
Julius Caesar, okay? So there's a wide
range of his plays. And so the question
is
how did he do it? Well,
he was stealing it from everyone, okay?
Remember this is a,
um, market There's a huge market for
theater and there are dozens and dozens
of really talented playwrights in
London, in England who are producing
wonderful works, okay? So he's just
stealing these plots from different, um,
playwrights. But what makes Shakespeare
unique and special and superior to these
other playwrights is first of all his
characters,
okay?
Um, he has a deep empathy
for
his characters. He goes into the mind of
his characters and he says, "If I'm this
person how would I behave?"
Okay? So that's one thing that makes him
unique. Second as we discussed is his
use of language,
okay? Just the fluidity
and the beauty, okay? And the
flexibility of his language,
okay? Um, and
the last thing is the realism which is
he's trying to
make the plot as realistic as possible.
He's trying to remove the supernatural
elements, okay? He's much He's
interested in psychology,
okay?
So, um, when you look at Othello
he's he's he's asking himself, "Why is
it that a man who loves his wife
what could drive him to kill his wife?"
Okay? That's the question he's asking.
He doesn't see Othello as a black person
in a foreign culture. He doesn't see it
that way. He just sees,
"I want to ask myself a question. If you
truly love a person what would what
would drive him
to kill
her?" Okay?
But because the theme is so universal
it allows you to
impose,
um, cultural readings,
okay? So he himself was not interested
in the issue of race, culture, and
identity. Quite honestly at this time in
history there's no such thing as race or
identity,
okay? Remember I keep I keep on saying
this but for most of you who of human
history we did not differentiate
ourselves according to race. We
differentiate ourselves according to
community,
okay? So within England
people didn't care about the French or
the Germans. They hate But but you know
what?
They cared about each other and they
hated each other. Remember the main
conflict in England at this point is the
conflict between the Catholics and the
Protestants, okay? So they won't focus
on the world, they'll focus on each
other.
So,
um, these cultural readings come later.
They come from today.
Shakespeare himself was only interested
in psychology. What drives us humans?
All right, and you can see that
manifests itself in Othello and in
Hamlet.
All right. And quite honestly,
I'll be honest with you, I think it's
really unfair to Shakespeare that we're
doing this.
All right. I mean like like like
like isn't it much It wouldn't be much
more interesting class if we stopped
asking ourselves, "Oh, Othello was a
black person. So, how black people are
persecuted?" And ask yourself, "Othello
is a man of great achievement. He's a
man of great tremendous pride and honor.
But is it possible that in in certain in
certain circumstances this can be used
against him?" And that's the And that's
the plot of Othello, which makes it a
Greek tragedy, right? The Greeks were
concerned about hubris,
arrogance,
fate. These are the questions that the
Greeks were concerned about. So, in many
ways Shakespeare saw himself as
continuing the Greek legacy.
All right. And the fact that we're
focusing on questions like race,
culture, and identity, it sort of like
degrades the play.
Because it's saying like, "Oh, if you're
a black person,
uh then you may always be manipulated
and persecuted." And quite honestly,
it's also reinforcing certain racial
stereotypes about black people as very
violent and emotional.
Okay. So, if I were to teach Othello,
it's a great play and I I've never
taught Othello, but I would focus more
on the human aspect of Othello as
opposed to the racial aspect of Othello.
Does that make sense?
Okay.
Great. Any more questions?
Oh my, is there any explanations for how
Shakespeare
is able to
produce such genius plays since he's not
very well educated as you mentioned?
That's a great question.
How is Shakespeare able to focus on
human psychology
given the fact that he's not well
educated? Okay, I will make the argument
it is
precisely because he's not well educated
that he focused on human psychology.
Okay? When you are educated, you're
educated into cultural attitudes, norms,
and values of the elite.
But if you're not educated, then what
you do is you observe humans as they are
without prejudice.
You want to know You want to know
how are we as humans?
And you have not been indoctrinated to
believe
believe certain certain things.
Okay? If you go to school, and you do
well in school, and you go to
university, the first thing you're
taught is only well educated people are
capable of deep psychological insights.
And that's a prejudice. That's a
failing.
Because Shakespeare never went to
school, he's able to see himself as
equal to other people, and therefore
he's able to have tremendous empathy for
the people, and therefore he's able to
understand their psychology and his own
psychology.
All right. He's able to see people as a
reflection of his own psychology, and
that's what drives his genius.
And quite honestly, that's also what
what drove Homer, okay?
So,
um I mean
um I I I hate to say this, okay, but I
did go to Yale University. I studied
English literature there, so I spent I
spent a year studying Shakespeare.
And
um
I was not impressed with the education I
got at at Yale because again, the
problem with one of these elite
universities is you're taught to think
in a very rigid way
that inhibit your empathy,
your curiosity,
and your own psychological
understanding.
Okay.
In fact, I'll be honest with you, um I
watch a lot of YouTube videos and like
to do research for these talks.
I'm always impressed by how these
self-taught historians know much more
about history
um than these academics at Yale,
Cambridge, Oxford, Harvard, okay? That I
mean that's that's something that I I
I've observed. Um you're much better off
talking to an individual who has a
passion for history
and who who's spent his entire life
asking himself, "What is history?"
but never really got a formal education,
never got a doctorate in history as
opposed to
a Harvard PhD in history.
Okay, that's that's that's that's a hard
lesson I learned in my life. It was very
hard for me for me to accept because I
am
um an elite
um graduate of of elite university.
Okay? But what Shakespeare understood
intuitively is no, it's the common
people,
the ordinary people,
that's where the truth lies. Okay? Not
in books, but in people. That's That's
what makes Shakespeare so great. He's He
is first and foremost
an anthropologist, a psychologist of
people. He wants to understand how
people think and behave.
Okay, when you read when you when you
read his plays, that's what that that's
what you experience for yourself, okay?
He's really interested in the psychology
of Iago, Desdemona, and Othello. Okay?
That's That's what he's That's what he's
curious about. He's not interested in
these structural forces that drive
conflict and persecution
uh among these people, okay? That comes
later. That That's That's what we do to
Shakespeare today. Okay, but back then
he was only he was only interested in
what it meant to be a human being.
Okay.
Does that make sense?
I go. Yes. Okay, great. Any more
questions, guys?
You want to ask more about Othello? I'd
I'd be happy to answer.
Even though my reading of Othello might
be different from what what you've been
taught in class. I've only read Act One,
so I'm
having having some trouble reading it.
Okay. Yeah, I was kind of curious how
like Shakespeare's thing of
these kind of
themes like Othello
like back then
in England. I don't really see much
literature about
race or
Okay, so the question is
how does
Shakespeare develop his themes? Okay, so
um
So, Othello
Sorry.
So, Othello, Hamlet,
King Lear, all these plays are well
known stories.
Okay, they're actually well well known
stories. But Shakespeare, he is curious
about people. All right, because every
day if you work in a theater, you you
deal with people all the time, okay?
Your customers are people, your actors
are people. And what he discovered over
time is people are very complicated.
People are very emotional. People have
um their own psychology. There's
diversity among people, okay? And so,
what he does that's really interesting
is he takes these legends and combines
them together, okay?
He takes these legends and he and he
takes his observations of human
individuals and combines them together
to create Shakespeare.
In other words,
what he does that's unique is he takes
these characters, King Lear, Hamlet, and
turns them into people he's observed.
All right. When you do that, you get you
get a lot of interesting psychology.
All right, so let's imagine
um you become Hamlet, and you're in the
circumstance where your father's come
and told and given you a mission to go
kill your uncle because he's sleeping
with, you know, your your your mother,
and um
how would you behave?
Well, you'd probably react like Hamlet,
and you'd be like
very confused. You'd be very distraught,
okay? Does that make sense? Same thing
with Othello where
um let's just say that you're this great
champion, you're this great hero. Well,
other people are are going to be jealous
of you.
Right? If other people are going to are
are going to be jealous of you, what
they're what they're going to do is
figure out how to um
get back at you, okay? So, it's not a
racial issue, it's a human issue.
If you're the top student in the school,
and every day the teachers are praising
you, right? I'm pretty sure that
teacher's going to hate your guts.
That's Othello.
Right? That's a human thing. It's not a
racial thing. It's not because he's
black, I mean it's because he's such a
uh accomplished individual.
Okay.
Does that make sense?
All right.
Great. Okay, so um next class we do the
Mexican Revolution, all right?